Speaker 1: So the so-called investigations into
voter fraud are continuing, the so-called audit
in Arizona is still going on, the one where
they're looking for bamboo fibers or chili
sauce droplets or leftover apple peels or whatever
it is that they're looking for that's continuing.
But there is one voter fraud investigation which
has concluded and that's been taking place in
Michigan. And we're going to look at the results.
This was importantly a Republican investigation. A
Republican investigation finds no Michigan voter
fraud and deems many claims ludicrous. Now, this
is not exclusively all logical from the Michigan
Republicans. I will get to that momentarily.
But the report out of Lansing says a month long
Republican investigation into Michigan's 2020
election uncovered no evidence of widespread fraud
and concluded Wednesday with a recommendation. The
attorney general investigate those who made the
claims for personal gain. The 35 page report dives
deep to debunk conspiracy theories perpetuated by
former President Trump and some of his supporters.
Remember that in Michigan, Biden won by about
one hundred and fifty five thousand votes,
while the Senate Oversight Committee investigation
revealed some glaring issues and vulnerabilities
the legislature should fix. Quote, There is no
evidence presented at this time to prove either
significant acts of fraud or that an organized,
wide scale effort to commit fraudulent activity
was perpetrated in order to subvert the
will of Michigan voters. Our clear finding
is that citizens should be confident the results
represent the true results of the ballots cast by
the people of Michigan. The committee strongly
recommend citizens use a critical eye and ear
toward those who have pushed demonstrably false
theories for their own personal gain. The report
concludes there is no proof of dead voters or
fractional voting, no evidence of a fraudulent
ballot dump in Detroit, and no proof any Michigan
precincts had more than one hundred percent voter
turnout. That's another claim that Donald Trump
made. So this is all well and good. And it's a
great thing. Except that except that some of the.
Things that are being recommended by Republicans
are still suppressive techniques that aren't
actually necessary given the absence of fraud. So
let's kind of go through this in two parts. If
there's one thing that should give us a little
bit of reassurance from twenty 20, it's that in
a sense, the legal system still worked in that it
didn't allow dozens and dozens of bogus lawsuits
or the Supreme Court, as Trump wanted to flip the
results of even a single state. Never mind the
election. You had more than 80 of these alleged
fraud cases brought forward in different
jurisdictions and courts demanded evidence.
The completely unreliable and sometimes
potentially delusional so-called eyewitnesses
were not enough in just presenting conspiracy
theories about what they think they saw or how
many sandwiches there were in a van that showed
up late at night in Michigan or wherever it was
the conjecture, the lies. The courts did not
allow that to push forward these bogus cases.
And more than 80 of these cases were thrown out
all across the country. In some situations. The
Trump legal team, which was this motley crew of
sometimes Rudy Giuliani when he didn't have covid
Jenna Ellis, I guess Cydney Powell was part of it,
although then when she was humiliating herself,
Trump said she was what whatever. Sometimes
they were even laughed out of court. OK, so
that's good. It's good that at least there was
this backstop where even some Trump appointed
judges said there's nothing here, we can't move
forward. The concerning part is that even these
Republicans who in Michigan said there's no
fraud, they have drafted a whole bunch of voting
restrictions to fix the system that they claim
has glaring deficiencies when in reality they are
just voter suppression tactics. So let's you know,
things are more complicated than black or white.
It's good that even Trump appointed judges didn't
allow this trash to move move forward. It's a good
thing that even the Michigan Republican Party
said there's no evidence of actual fraud here.
But that very same Republican Party in Michigan
is participating in some of these more than
two hundred and fifty nationwide bills to further
restrict voting. So like most things in life,
it's not exactly black and white. It is, in a
sense, a victory that Republicans straight up said
there's no evidence of fraud, but we still need to
be fighting them as far as we're concerned when it
comes to the voting of voter suppression that they
are pushing and Republicans all over the country
are pushing. But it shouldn't shock anybody that
a serious look at the allegations in all states,
but in this case in Michigan did not turn up
any of the fraud that they claim took place.